Oh further here and I gave you life yet
[Music]
I'm here with my dad and cuicci to
Austrian maniacs you [__] works
really hard to make an electric twister
[Music]
the invention something very special
ready
you
maybe not a place lingering Picasso
[Music]
doesn't look anything like a dick not a
great job 13 years ago in your bottle of
my fish it is and you saved it this
whole time was it better
I've asked on my social media for
someone to bring me a drug testing kits
we can find out how many drugs where my
sister's back on thank you babe laughter
goes scientifically I think we've
determined that drugs are [__] last
for 13 years if that disappointing [__]
having my own two story tour bus is cool
with me thank you so much describing my
balls my dick on the bus there are very
[__] few of us yeah
parents Colin you're not dressed up to
TJ
this fish items on this [__] yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it just me and done yeah thank you
now internet Nemo from the bonds gonna
smile Edison and she was like three
donkeys thank God for your accent this
crazy get a real mention England you
know Judy buying tickets yeah I replied
to your fan mail in 2008 it was I
writing a tattoo its life is easy and
everything went your way the whole time
he was before
Wow as rare as it gets
yeah that's upside down fever in there
that was when people were like holy [__]
he's actually come for something on if I
could kill that
[Music]
so going into France here huh
alright heartless is very mentally walk
through an airport here in Belgium my
man Quinton made Scott Randolph the most
secured ever doing that yeah share
Denmark they got goofy ass bikes man and
they like court even welcome second
Denmark so cool in Holland they [__]
with bikes so much we're talking about
double stacks
[Music]
looking in Holland
the German your name said dynam dynamo
know what do you you know waiting are
you okay the documentary the greased car
ran off night did I pick up present for
you you again you gave me the head to
and then international stardom girl haha
and Carmela
[__] a man is badass dude yeah tell me
this is the Berlin Wall yeah huh what's
this excuse me this is the Berlin Wall
[Music]
guys hit Berlin Wall yeah I said I
knocked it down didn't they knock it
down a little I think it at all
half-drawn
so there you have it that's the
[__] Berlin Wall
[Applause]
[__] impressive dude did I ever did
this is incredible
you can thank you for driving
so great another great [__] piece of
art thank you a sad farewell goodbye
through the bus dip airplane if you're
still watching this video you are one of
my biggest fans I want to say thank you
so much
also I just relaunched my website
totally new version with a bitching
online store that has an autograph book
autographed posters I grab comedy
special DVDs all kinds of bitchin
t-shirts and [__] hat and hoodies I'm
in you gotta grab that stuff and I love
you so much thank you again Stevo calm
you